most people in this world are naive like
I was when I entered the work world most
people don't understand the 48 Laws of
Power they don't understand that you
want to talk less to appear more
powerful they don't understand the
dynamic of making people come to you
instead of always kind of foisting
yourself on others and that naivete is
what gets you into a lot of trouble in
life right it got me into a lot of
trouble law number One never outshine
the master I could I could sit here and
cry and tell you all kinds of tragic
stories about how I outshold the master
and how miserable it made me right so I
was one of those people who was a bit
and I even didn't understand this kind
of secret language that power that
people in power have so a lot of the
book is opening it up this world to
everyone